استمر المواجهات بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني وعلى مختلف المحاور في
الجبهتين الشرقيه والجنوبيه وسطمرار
المحاولات الاوكرانيه لاحداث ثغره في
الخطوط العسكريه الروسيه مع دخول الهجوم
المضاد شهره الثاني
بشان القنابل العنقوديه يستمر تبادل
الاتهامات بين الطرفين وجديدها اتهام
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في دونيتس
للقوات الروسيه باستخدام القذائف
العنقوديه في قصف المدنيين ما ادى الى
سقوط ضحايا بينهم اطفال
وكانت العاصمه الاوكرانيه تعرضت لهجوم جوي
روسي وقال رئيس الاداره العسكريه
ان القوات الروسيه هاجمت الليله الماضيه
العاصمه الاوكرانيه لطائرات مسيره من نوع
الشاهد واضاف انه تم تدمير المسيرات كافه
وذلك عند اقترابها من كيف من قبل قوات
الدفاع الجوي واشار وقوع الى عدم سقوط
ضحايا